A game for those who seek to find a way to leave their world behind.
Jumanji.
You pick a character and you're that person in the game.
Which one do I pick?
I don't think it matters that much.
Moose Finbar, sounds like a badass.
I'll be the curvy genius.
Dr. Smolder Bravestone.
I guess I'm Ruby Roundhouse.
Guys!
Oy vey!
Where's the rest of me?
My God!
Fridge?!
Yeah, I'm Fridge.
Who are you?
It's me, Spencer.
Who is she?
Martha?
Why I'm wearing half a shirt and short shorts in the jungle?
I think we got sucked into Jumanji and we've become the avatars we chose.
So that means?
Bethany?
Oh no, Bethany.
Don't look at it!
No!
I'm an overweight middle-aged man.
I don't have my Claritin and all I see around here is pollen!
Well, I don't have the top two feet of my body!
Maybe we're all in a coma.
What?
That old game machine must have electrocuted us and now we're...
Oh my God!
You better get in there to save her.
I am not gonna get in there!
You get in there.
Yeah, I got a backpack on.
You don't get in water with a backpack.
Everybody knows that.